was about into the stadium so could we
implement the current CDC guidelines the
state guidelines or physical distancing
mass requirements and all those type of
things in an outdoor environment and
have obviously significantly less fans
than what we are used to I think it's
possible we have played a little bit
with the social distancing concept and
we know that that probably would take us
down south of 30 about 30,000 fans in
the stands actually closer to 20 to 22
[Music]
state athletic director Jean Smith on
the question of how many fans able cram
into Ohio Stadium I have been there it
is crazy on game days and you saw the
photos it's it's I don't know what will
look stranger Chris no fans at all or
some sort of a bizarre checkerboard
pattern or fans that are six feet apart
or it's gonna be weird either way and it
may be weirder to see half capacity or a
third of a capacity they're talking
about anywhere from twenty two thousand
to fifty thousand if they can relax the
guidelines a little bit all the way up
to fifty thousand he's just gonna look
weird to not have full capacity and and
it wouldn't just be everyone clustered
in the lower bowl in the upper bowl
emptied it's gonna be people just like
all over the place that's gonna be a
strange thing to see on TV it definitely
will be I think it very odd
ain't no college football I think you
know just in general will be a little
odd you know without the the pageantry
and wouldn't eat of the bands what are
they gonna do they get spread out the
band like in the end zone to where
they're not they're still playing music
but they're five six feet away from each
other then the band is such a big part
of college football so you know again I
think college football has a lot more
work to do than the NFL there's a lot
more moving pieces and I'm I'm truly
intrigued to see where it goes and if
they if they can play games get students
on campus feeling healthy and you know
do fans want to go to the games
I'm gonna be interesting they've made it
clear that you can't have college
football without college so the campus
does have to be open before they're
gonna play college football but I think
that definition of the term campus open
is going to be a very loose one it could
be that the vast majority of the classes
are done online with minimal gatherings
but still campus is open know but make
some decisions they got it you know
people have to decide what am I gonna
get a lease in the town where the
college is am I gonna sign that lease
and commit to it now what am I gonna do
what am I gonna be there where am I
gonna be what's going on so from a
school standpoint they need to make
decisions from a football standpoint
they need to make decisions and let me
tell you this I don't want to be overly
cynical here but I think at the end of
the day even if they only have twenty
two thousand thirty thousand people Ohio
Stadium when they put the price tag on
those tickets when when you're gonna be
one of the chosen few that gets in that
ain't gonna be free and it's not gonna
be what it costs when you're in there
with ninety thousand people they are
gonna make back that money because if
there's only one-third of the capacity
the tickets are going to be three times
more expensive and if you don't want to
buy it one of those other people will
probably yes at places like Ohio State
they could get away with that now I
don't know if some of the
middle-of-the-road colleges are gonna be
able to get away with that right that
that would be concerning there you know
there there I think you know I don't
think they'd be able to pull that off
but a place they call a day they're
probably I know you're right their
problem yeah they should and they have
it they built a great tradition there
they have an unbelievable alumni base
you know and they got people that are
willing to pay money to go see that
football team and donate and make the
campus better and make the stadium
better the facility better so you know
that would be one of those schools that
could probably do that and the alumni
would still pay it just to be there and
to ensure that the players are all
always fully compensated for their
abilities their risking their sacrifices
oh wait alright here's the thing here's
the thing they are going to try to
continue to maintain the facade that
this is some sort of a corollary to the
academic experience
Loney it's billion-dollar business and
they're doing what they can to save it
and I would have so much more respect
for the entire college football system
if they would just admit it we all know
it
Creek this is this I use this example
all the time we all know wrestling is
fake go ahead and tell us but see the
reason they won't tell us is because the
moment they do that's when they do have
to give these kids more than tuition
room and board and snacks and everything
but fair value for their service
you